[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe nous sommes
une nouvelle fois au parlement européen
de bruxelles notre invité pour cette
émission et pascal durand eurodéputée
écologiste d'ile-de-france ensemble nous
allons tenter de répondre à une question
l'europe est elle assez ambitieuses pour
l'environnement vaste sujet donc au
programme nous vous présenterons aussi
durant cette émission celles et ceux qui
ont bâti l'union européenne avec un zoom
aujourd'hui sur le parcours de nicole
fontaine il sera est question également
de moralisation de la vie publique
premier texte porté sous la présidence d
emmanuel macron nous verrons ce qu'il en
est chez nos voisins européens
[Musique]
pascal durand bonsoir ça avocat de
formation vous avez intégré la sphère
écologiste si je puis dire en 2006
concrètement en tout cas voilà deux ans
plus tard vous fondez avec daniel cohn
bendit europe ecologie les verts vous
avez été aussi secrétaire national du
parti entre 2012 et 2013 puis tête de
liste en ile-de-france pour les
européennes de 2014 c'est donc votre
premier mandat électoral une question
comme ça un peu un peu de curieuses est
ce que vous pensez déjà à 2019 aux
prochaines élections européennes est ce
que vous serez candidat ce que vous avez
envie de l'être ou alors peut-être vous
avez envie de connaître un autre échelon
électorale dans votre parcours politique
non alors déjà je peux répondre
facilement la dernière question un autre
et les chants électorale non moi j'avais
vraiment fait le choix de l'europe j'ai
abandonné ma vie professionnelle après
30 ans d'un métier passionnant et que
j'adorais que j'aime toujours dans
l'absolu
justement à cause de l'europe c'est
vraiment un choix pour pour moi la clé
envie d'agir et m oui la question
européenne est une question majeure
c'est un levier absolument essentiel
pour les idées auxquelles je crois pour
répondre à la question climatique et
environnementale d'une manière générale
mais pas que
industrielle sociale je pense que
l'europe ait vraiment de bons espaces
donc si j'ai un mandat à reprendre si je
dois aller sur un deuxième mandat ça
sera un mandat européen après je vais
pas faire de la langue de bois
on a des difficultés à porter à l'europe
quand on a de vraies convictions on a
des difficultés à porter ce qu'on croit
souvent c'est le matin en disant voilà
je vais essayer d'avoir ça et puis on se
couche le soir on l'a on l'a rarement eu
on a des victoires mais bon c'est
compliqué et il ya un moment où on se
dit
après tout est-ce que
est ce que c'est vraiment la place d'un
écologiste c'est une vraie question je
devrais pas l'imposer comme ça parce que
ça paraît un peu défaitiste mais je la
pose comme ça on aura l'occasion peut
être en tout cas c'est un vrai
questionnement d'ici 2019 chaque mois
nous vous faisons découvrir celles et
ceux qui ont participé à la construction
européenne ce mois ci nicole fontaine
elle fut président du parlement européen
de 99 à 2002 l'une des seule femme à
avoir occupé ce poste avec simone veil
est vingt ans plus tôt son parcours et
ses principales actions avec philippe le
guen directeur de l'association jean
monnet est basée dans les yvelines
[Musique]
nicole fontaine elle a été très
longtemps
député européen depuis
1984 et a été pendant dix ans députée
européenne est très active sur le toutes
les questions vraiment de rapprocher
l'europe des citoyens c'était son sujet
vous savez elle vient du monde de
l'éducation en france elle a été
longtemps dans le au sein du ministère
l'éducation chargé de l'éducation
catholique des relations entre
l'éducation catholique et les duels et à
chacun évidemment
à sa personnalité
peut-être aussi ses affinités et donc
elle avait vraiment cette fibre de
vouloir rapprocher
l'europe des citoyens européens ce qui
avait commencé à faire simone veil
évidemment un donc elle a continué ce
travail il ya eu simone veil 20 ans
avant moi la première présidente du
parlement européen puis il a fallu
attendre vingt ans pour
que le parlement élise à nouveau une
femme j'espère qu'on n'attendra pas à
nouveau 20 ans pour élire une nouvelle
femme elle a été à l'origine aussi des
grands lancements enfin pour la partie
du parlement européen mais qui
co-décident un des politiques grand
lancement des programmes tels qu'erasmus
les programmes aussi qui permettent de
rapprocher l'europe des citoyens réduire
la distance ça c'est vrai que
modestement parce qu'on veut pas tout
faire ça a été une de mes ambitions et
puis deuxième ambition faire exister le
parlement européen sur la scène
extérieure et puis aussi une troisième
ambition bien marquer que nous ne sommes
pas seulement un marché commun un marché
unique mais que nous sommes une
communauté de valeurs et de destin
partagé et puis également elle a été
elle a marqué par ce qu'elle a écrit
plusieurs livres de vulgarisation un
petit peu sur le fonctionnement de
l'europe des programmes du parlement
européen donc elle a permis vraiment de
rendre cette institution beaucoup plus
compréhensible pour les citoyens
l'idéal européen s'est sensiblement
émoussé au cours des dernières années il
nous faudra beaucoup de foi et de
pédagogie pour allumer la flamme
[Musique]
à
pascal durand si je vous pose la
question simplement comme ça comme s'il
s'agissait finalement d'un devoir pour
un lycéen l'europe est elle assez
ambitieuses pour l'environnement que
diriez-vous sans chiffres sans préalable
de réflexion que diriez vous est ce que
vous seriez plutôt positif optimiste ou
plutôt pessimiste lors je serai réaliste
et la réalité c'est que l'europe fait
beaucoup pour l'environnement elle fait
beaucoup elle fait beaucoup plus que ce
que font les 28 états pour le moment à
travers l'europe puisque on voit que
fréquemment c'est la transcription de
directive européenne sur la qualité de
l'eau sur la qualité de l'air sur la
question des émissions c'est l'union
européenne qui donne le la pour les
payer l'union européenne qui est le
vraiment le lieu où on essaye de
d'harmoniser les normes
environnementales voilà donc est ce
qu'elle fait pour l'environnement oui
est ce qu'elle fait suffisamment ben
c'est pareil pour un peu comme avoir
fait antithèse là mais pour un
écologiste ont fait jamais assez bien
sûr il ya des ya dedans il ya des vraies
avancées encore une fois l'air qu'on
respire l'eau que l'on boit ça c'est si
on avait le respect des normes
européennes on sentirait mieux il y
aurait moins de maladies respiratoires
notamment il y aurait bon on résout pas
tout à travers la question
environnementale bien sûr non résout
beaucoup à travers à travers des normes
sur la santé sur sur la chimie sur la
pollution alimentaires etc votre message
est donc plutôt positif oui pour le
réseau européen le savent pas forcément
puisqu'on dit toujours qu'il ya un
désamour entre l'union européenne et les
européens là vous avez un message
positif oui ils ne sont pas au courant
la faute à qui et pourquoi alors d'abord
et avant tout à une à une
mauvaise communication
de la part de nos dirigeants politiques
nationaux c'est pas pour renvoyer la
balle mais c'est simplement à chaque
fois qu'ils vont à brut d'abord on parle
jamais ou presque dans les médias je
vous dis ça mais je devrais pas mais
télévision locale et on parle pas
suffisamment en tout cas voilà on va
dire ça comme ça et et notamment par
rapport aux autres pays européens
l'espagne l'italie l'allemagne
s'intéresse ni haine de l'autre et
émissions sur l'europe il ya des vraies
pages europe à l'intérieur des journaux
des bons mais laissons ça compte et met
donc à on n'en parle pas assez d'eux ne
relie pas l'europe à la réalité par
exemple je ne suis jamais invités à
l'inauguration d'un centre de formation
professionnelle
alors que l'europe finance en règle
générale à 50% ces centres la bomba et
puis il ya les dirigeants français qui à
chaque fois qu'ils vont à bruxelles on a
l'impression qu'ils vont à la guerre ces
terres qui reviennent avec des victoires
ou avec des défaites ou avez-vous avec
l'opinion peut-être y opinion mais tout
ce qui va mal c'est la faute de l'europe
et puis tout ce qui va bien évidemment
c'est franco français ça n'est pas
raisonnable ça n'est pas sérieux ça
n'est pas comme ça qu'on va créer une
vraie dynamique entre l'espace européen
et l'espace régional l'espace des
territoires à l'intérieur de chacun des
pays alors on va évoquer évidemment
cette politique environnementale si on
se penche sur les chiffres l'union
européenne s'est fixé des objectifs
clairs nets et précis notamment à
l'horizon 2020 et puis 2030 si on prend
l'horizon 2030 réduction à certains
chiffres des gaz à effet de serre de 40%
par rapport à 90 27 % d'énergies
renouvelables quand on n'est pas
forcément experts qu'on sait pas ce que
valent ces chiffres concrètement on a
l'impression d'une ambition mais aussi
là un peu peut mieux faire comme si ça
suffisait à avoir 10 sur 20 mai mais on
ne prend pas le risque de trop en faire
pendant une meilleure note alors vous
poser vraiment la nouvelle dans la
vienne va raison mais vous poser la
bonne question c'est à dire en réalité
on se focalise sur les chiffres et donc
il ya eu des bagarres est-ce qu'il faut
30% est-ce qu'il faut 27% est ce qu'il
faut alors certains vont vous dire il
faudrait 40 d'autres dans la réalité
c'est que ce qu'on voudrait voir ces les
politiques publiques communes
et l ambitieuse c'est à dire que ce que
l'on veut et ce que vous voudrez mais au
delà des gens ce que l'on veut nous tout
simplement sait où va l'europe qu'est ce
qu'elle fait est ce qu'on doit continuer
à dire dans va financer le charbon en
pologne est ce qu'on va continuer à
financer les renouvelables en allemagne
et moins de charbon le nucléaire en
france n'est ce que j'aimerais voir
c'est une véritable politique commune
comme il ya eu dans le passé pour des
sujets important c'est qu'on ait une
véritable politique commune sur
l'énergie sur la question du climat et
que finalement on fasse preuve d'une
grande maturité là dessus parce qu'on
voit très bien que l'énergie le prix de
l'énergie augmentent énormément de
difficultés autour de l'énergie il faut
qu'on arrive à avoir une europe qui soit
à la hauteur des enjeux et qu'ils soient
au rendez-vous est vraiment moins les
pages ali et j'allais justement vous
vous posez la question est ce que un peu
comme sur l'europe de la défense sur les
problèmes migratoires est ce qu'en fait
c'est 28 voix différente ou alors qu'il
ya un message commun est ce que c'est
chacun sa intérêts chacun son industrie
chacun ses emplois et puis et puis peu
importe ce que fait l'autre ou ce que
pense l'autre alors il ya les deux vous
savez c'est les deux il ya notamment la
france avec le même billet nucléaire
notamment la france mais pas que le
nucléaire se dire que en fait il ya les
mots quand vous prenez le discours du
président de la république à la sorbonne
que moi j'ai salué parce que c'est ça
fait très longtemps qu'il ya plus un
président comme ça qui pose la question
européenne qui la met en avant qui la
revendique donc ça c'est une excellente
chose mais derrière les gens attendent
du concret et des actes donc
concrètement une europe de la diplomatie
une europe de la défense une robe de
l'énergie une europe agricoles
commencent à se déclinent comment est ce
qu'on la met en oeuvre donc il faut pas
simplement porter des ambitions
européennes de principe il faut aussi
les actes et par exemple le budget
européen compte le président de la
république dit je veux un budget pour
l'europe nous aussi on veut un budget
pour l'europe bien sûr mais ce budget il
est financé comment uniquement par les
états par des budgets propres par
exemple la taxe sur les transactions
financières européennes de manière à ce
qu'on ne porte pas atteinte à la
concurrence en interne pourquoi est ce
qu'elle est toujours pas mises en oeuvre
depuis 2008 promise alors que jallet
vous posez la question même si vous
n'êtes entre guillemets que eurodéputés
que vous n'êtes paris avec des tatouages
chaussée s'est envolée linéaire alors
qu'ils avaient un pouvoir politique
alors pourquoi pourquoi ça pourquoi ça
bloque mais savoir ce que et parce que
pour répondre je n'avais pas assez de
pouvoirs au parlement ou non parce que
on est le seul espace démocratique sur
cette planète planète pardon à être
encore les gestations avec le parlement
d'un côté et puis le conseil donc les
représentants des états des autres en
gros c'est comme si la france
l'assemblée vote une loi et puis une
fois que la loi est votée eh bien vous
avez le gouvernement qui dit oh bah non
finalement cette fois elle me plaît pas
on va la renégocier on va rediscuter etc
ça se passe comme ça alors on dira que
le parlement européen qui représente les
européens est beau les gens des lieux
mais aussi que les décideurs bien sûr
que les et par après je parlais par
exemple de la question vous vous
envisagez l'énergie quand on arrive à
discuter au niveau des étapes quand y'a
pas un espace général européen une
défense de l'intérêt général européen
c'est un peu après la foire d'empoigné
en disant ben oui mais moi vous mettez
des fonds sur le renouvelable mais le
renouvelable c'est quoi les énergies
douces et quoi est-ce que le nucléaire
c'est une énergie qui doit être
considérée comme non carbonées enfin et
donc ces débats-là bloque toute vision
générale en fait qui se passe c'est
qu'on a une commission européenne qui
est beaucoup trop faible la commission
européenne devrait indépendante des et
l'union européenne elle est censée
représenter l'intérêt général européen
comme nous nous on le fait honnêtement
c'est pas pour dire je vous assure que
les députés y travaille vraiment à
essayer de faire l'intérêt général
européen alfred que la commission soit
un peu plus là dessus et un peu moins
sûr je représente les états puisqu'on
parle d'environnement parlons d'une
politique environnementale celle de
l'énergie par exemple si on avait une
vraie politique européenne énergie à
quoi ça ressemblerait concrètement
qu'est-ce que ça à définir et quelle est
la capacité à tenir les objectifs par
exemple c'est à dire que quand on a
fixerait par exemple le pourcentage de
ça nous permettrait de développer les
énergies renouvelables pour avoir la
seule énergie sur lequel nous ayons une
indépendance à terme à l'horizon 2050 ce
sont les énergies renouvelables les
éoliennes
la biomasse le solaire etc ça on sait
qu'on n'a pas besoin de l'importer on
l'a en europe on importe 400 milliards
donc ça peu près par obliger les
énergies mais oui ça donc ça voudrait
dire que l'europe devrait fixer ce cap
avec évidemment des périodes
intermédiaires à personne a dit qu'on va
appuyer sur un bouton demain matin que
de charbon plus de nucléaire plus ça
n'existe pas nulle part personne ne
croit ça mais à 20 25 30 ans sur une
énergie on peut avoir des plans et
surtout avoir des intermédiaires et des
obligations c'est à dire qu'on se
contente pas d'être dans le déclaratif
mais qu'on regarde et que les états
rendre compte des politiques publiques
qu'ils ont mis en oeuvre et des
résultats et qu'ils soient sanctionnés
par était déjà en débattaient ne parle
de 27 % d'énergies renouvelables en 2030
mais si on n'y arrive pas il se passe
rien c'est pendant cette réunion c'est
sale nom le match que j'aimerais c'est
pas pour punir pour le sais pas ça c'est
simplement que si un état qui vit aussi
pour une grande part des subventions
européennes
avaient des objectifs à tenir et que si
ces objectifs ne sont pas tenus sauf
évidemment explications raison peut y
avoir plein de raisons objectives mais
s'il ne fait pas l'effort par exemple la
france la france toujours bien c'est mon
sens d'énergie rodrigues hydraulics en
2020 brille encore pourrait ça pourrait
on pourrait par exemple
une ironie revient sur la foule europe
finance et que la france ne respecte pas
ses objectifs eh bien il faudrait qu'il
y ait des sanctions qui tombent mais pas
d'un coup mais simplement qu'on puisse
mettre en demeure en disant attention
vous n'atteignez pas objectif nous on a
la chance d'avoir eu de l'hydraulique
qui a été préparée il ya des années
heureusement ça nous permet d'avoir une
part d'énergie renouvelable qui n'est
pas totalement ridicule mais de fait on
fait aucun effort sérieux et par
ailleurs on continue à surinvestir dans
la question nucléaire est sous investir
sur les énergies renouvelables alors
plus que vous me tendez la perche
l'actualité en tout cas l'une des
actualités il ya quelques il ya quelques
semaines en france était l' annonce du
gouvernement et de nicolas hulot que la
réduction de la part du nucléaire dans
la production d'électricité allait être
repoussé cette caduque sion a été prévu
initialement en 2025 pour passer de 75 à
50% nicolas hulot a reconnu que ce
n'était pas possible à moins de de
conserver les usines à charbon nous voir
en ouvrir de nouvelles est-ce que c est
ce que c'est juste d'après vous est ce
que aujourd'hui la force n'a pas l'hymne
à réduire sa part du nucléaire dans la
production des concessions ou alors elle
ne s'en donne pas les moyens voilà je ne
sais pas je n'ai donc pas polémiquer
c'est
donc très proches mais bien sûr et aidés
dont je respecte et les convictions et
l'engagement est encore une fois nicolas
est quelqu'un dont on a besoin alors là
vraiment s'il ya quelqu'un dont on a
besoin dans ce gouvernement c'est de
nicolas hulot mais la réalité c'est que
cet objectif de réduction à 50% en 2025
il devait suivre une trajectoire ou part
d'un point à était le point 2013 quand
le président hollande dit il faut aller
vers cela c'est une annonce du président
de la république on a en 2013 2010 2015
ça rentre dans la loi donc ça devient
force de loi donc la loi tout le monde
doit la respecter enfin vous respecter
les feux rouges je vois pas pourquoi le
gouvernement s'exonère
2015 et en arrivant 2017 rien n'a été
fait on n'a pas fermé de centrales
nucléaires on a pas et on peut pas
mettre un coup d'accélérateur en espace
on a perdu des grands bien sûr on
pourrait le faire mais simplement un
lien de voir aussi de vérité il ya un
moment où nicolas hulot aurait dû dire
il l'a dit mais un peu trop tard il
aurait dû dire on n'a pas respecté les
engagements sur la période 2013 2017
donc maintenant on est dans une
situation très compliquée pour 2025 sans
être brutal après
hilal annonce elle a été un peu rapide
uniquement basé sur des scénarios rte
rte c'est une filiale d'edf et on sait
le lien qu edf a avec le nucléaire donc
bon peut-être qu'on pourrait aller vers
un peu plus expertise indépendante je
crois que nicolas hulot s'est engagé sur
ce point j'attends bien sûr très
prochainement le le nouveau plan de
manière à ce qu'on atteigne quand même
c'est 50% une réflexion un peu plus
générale maintenant le vieux continent
est le troisième pollueur au monde r la
chine et les états unis est-ce qu'on
pourrait selon vous concrètement elle
est plus loin que les chiffres dont on a
évoqué alors vous m'avez déjà répondu
que oui mais dire concrètement dans
quelques décennies que l'union
européenne pourrait être un continent
complètement vert et finalement être un
modèle pour le monde entier ce qu'on a
les capacités et puis et puis ça sera
aussi une porte pour pour lutter contre
le chômage la transition écologique est
ce qu'on peut devenir d'ici 20 à 30 ans
complètement vert mais alors
complètement vers j'en sais rien
maintenant est-ce que cet objectif on a
la capacité de le mettre en oeuvre la
réponse est clairement oui on peut le
faire il ya des études mais mais très
très clairs notamment de l'onu qui à
l'horizon 2050 nous nous expliquons peut
être sur une énergie positive qu'on aura
plus besoin d'importer d'énergies
fossiles ou peut le faire la question
qu'on sait que ça va créer des millions
d'emplois je dis bien des millions
d'emplois ça va relocaliser notre
industrie il faut qu'on baisse les
productions dans les pays
éloigné avec des coûts de transport
subventionnés qui nous coûte une fortune
et dans des conditions au plus de
production qui sont scandaleuses sur un
plan social et environnemental il faut
qu'on relocalise il faut qu'on protège
le continent européen et il faut qu'on
se donne les moyens de
redévelopper à nouveau une industrie de
effectivement d'être dans une énergie et
une agriculture beaucoup plus verte est
positif on peut le faire c'est bon pour
tout le monde pour l'emploi et pour la
planète on parle souvent du couple
franco franco-allemand sur toutes les
thématiques est ce que là aussi sur sûr
sur cette problématique environnementale
la france et l'allemagne ont ce rôle
moteur à jouer ou alors c'est un peu une
vision archaïque de toujours penser au
moteur franco-allemand si on en a besoin
en réalité c'est ça a été une grande
part des locomotives c'est les deux pays
les plus importants et en terme de
population et en termes économiques et
pas les plus verts aujourd'hui parce
qu'on insiste sur ce mot vers la cité
des jarres et % d'énergie renouvelable
et bien sûr le danemark fait aussi
beaucoup d'efforts on n'est pas dans un
même contexte et pas les mêmes c'est pas
les mêmes six thouars donc il ya un
moment où moi je dis souvent comparaison
n'est pas raison la france ou
l'allemagne ça n'est pas la suède ou le
danemark on n'a pas la même là là même
les mêmes déplacements les mêmes
territoires mais simplement on peut
effectivement se donner des orientations
la france et l'allemagne ont su le faire
dans le passé on a su le faire sur le
charbon et l'acier faisons le là sur
notre industrie sur les énergies
nouvelles il peut y arriver il ya une
question de volonté politique après
attention il faut pas que la france et
l'allemagne constitue le noyau unix en
ouverture non parce que sinon on va
avoir une europe où un certain nombre de
pays à la périphérie on commence à le
voir notamment avec la pologne avec la
hongrie etc vont se sentir complètement
en dehors de ce schéma là et on va être
comme dans une classe où il y aurait des
bons élèves et où on abandonne à la fin
de la classe les mauvais élèves c'est
pas une bonne idée surtout quand les
mauvais élèves deviennent plus nombreux
que les bons donc ça c'est pas non plus
la solution sur toutes les questions
européennes il faut de la france
allemagne mais pas que parce qu'elles
ont encore une question ce n'est pas moi
qui vais la pause et c'est la dernière
de cette émission qui n'est pas
forcément en lien avec notre sujet
d'actualité c'est un maire et puis
conseiller départemental qui vous la
pose des yvelines vous avez juste à
cliquer là l écoute et puis vous pourrez
lui répondre juste après bonjour je suis
karl olive maire de poissy je suis
heureux de pouvoir vous poser une
question la vérité c'est que j'aimerais
pouvoir avoir l'honneur de faire votre
connaissance je suis profondément
européen j'ai été élu en 2014 je suis
conseiller général depuis 2011 j'étais
journaliste auparavant depuis une
quinzaine d'années ici sur le territoire
je n'ai jamais vu un député européen sur
le terrain vous venez sur le terrain
c'est la vérité qui parle et la vérité
c'est celle du terrain
pascal durand vous attaquent pas vous
pernaut c'est les eurodéputés en général
pas son visage on est
sur le terrain yvelinois ge on voit
rarement des eurodéputés en déplacement
ou autre vous disiez tout à l'heure on
vous invite pas comme ça mais si vous
venez de vous même à la main mais je
viens je pense qu'il a pas une semaine
où je ne suis pas en déplacement j'en ai
visité deux de jay de visiter des
centres de ressources riches allaient et
visiter des agriculteurs tout ça dans
les dents les jours qui viennent de
passer donc ça n'est pas vrai je suis
allé dans 92 je suis allé dans le 91 je
suis allée maintes fois
dans le 95 et donc et à paris aussi bien
sûr juste pour les autres re député
peut-être oui non a lâché moi je peux
pas répondre pour les autres je peux
dire que et là vraiment je veux bien mon
agenda est publié je réponds à toutes
les invitations donc que le maire de
poissy qui visiblement est quelqu'un de
convaincu sur l'europe m'invite et je
vous garantis que je serai à poissy mais
je vais partout on me demande d'aller et
là où l'europe a une utilité maintenant
je répète nous ne sommes jamais invités
j'ai quand même pas simple de s'y
inviter un député européen à venir dans
sa ville voilà je sais tu pas pour
envoyer mais je vous assure que je
viendrais on en vient maintenant à notre
dernière rubriques de l'émission et chez
nos voisins ça se passe comment
interdiction des emplois familiaux
parlement suppression des indemnités de
frais de mandat des parlementaires
remplacé par des notes de frais voilà la
règle maintenant en france mais la
transparence et la moralisation de la
vie publique comment ça se passe du coup
chez nos voisins éléments de réponse
avec olivier jeanne l'ex responsable du
centre europe direct à saint germain en
laye
[Musique]
on a des législations qui sont
complètement différentes alors par
exemple dans certains pays nantis qu on
n'a pas de législation en fait c'est
juste de la tradition et une pression
morale qui est une pression morale et
civique qui est suffisamment forte mais
dans d'autres pays on peut penser
notamment à l'espagne ou au portugal on
a des législations qui ont été mis en
place afin de tenter d'encadrer ou de
réglementer le la transparence en vie
dans la vie politique concernant les
assistants parlementaires si on prend le
cas de la suède les assistants
parlementaires sont fournies par le
parti politique c'est pas le député qui
choisit son assistant parlementaire
l'assistant parlementaire et on va dire
nommé fournies par le parti politique
ainsi que rémunéré par le parti
politique on a aussi le cas en espagne
où le les assistants parlementaires sont
aussi nommés rémunérés et en fait c'est
même un système un peu différent parce
que c'est le parlement qui va définir le
nombre d'assistants parlementaires qui
va être affecté à chaque parti politique
dont classé directement le parlement qui
va décider
après on a d'autres pays notamment
l'italie ou en fait là c'est on va dire
un peu open bar où c'est les députés qui
choisissent leurs assistants
parlementaires qui peuvent nommer qui
veulent ça peut être des manques de leur
famille concernant l'indemnité des
parlementaires
tout dépend de ce qui est effectivement
prévue dans chaque état est en fait la
plupart du temps l'indemnité va dépendre
du niveau de vie principalement du pays
par exemple si on prend le cas de la
roumanie
l'indemnité de 1195 euros par mois ça
paraît peu par rapport à
un député français mais par rapport au
niveau de vie sur place c'est énormément
il est aussi une autre considération qui
en rentrant je sais que certains pays on
va dire sur rémunère et je mets sur
rémunère entre guillemets sur rémunère
certains parlementaires afin d'éviter de
la corruption c'est notamment le cas de
l'italie où on a une rémunération qui a
plus de dix mille euros et cette
surrémunération est justement mis en
place afin d'éviter des cas de
corruption alors la lutte contre les
conflits d'intérêts se fait
principalement par la transparence et
par le droit de regard des citoyens les
cas des pays nordiques sont assez
intéressants en la matière parce que là
on a une pression civique et morale qui
est extrêmement qui est extrêmement
importante toutes les dépenses sont
censés être public s'il arrive une
situation où par exemple un
parlementaire paye des courses
personnelles avec la avec la carte de
son parti politique il est obligé de
démissionner même s'il a remboursé par
la suite de les dépenses engagées avec
son argent personnel
[Musique]
merci pascal durand d'avoir participé à
7,8 europe je rappelle que vous êtes
euro députée des verts en ile de france
merci à vous vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission replay sur notre site internet
et commenter sur nos réseaux sociaux tv
78 la semaine prochaine vous retrouverez
le 7-8 politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]